these are all of the volcanoes in the
world
you've got this big strip here in
ethiopia a big cluster up in iceland
and a long strip down the west coast of
the americas
but there's one spot that has more
volcanoes than anywhere else on earth
right here in indonesia and it's not
even
all of indonesia this country of 17 000
islands it's really this belt right here
this is called the sunda arc and it's
where the majority of volcanic activity
in indonesia is happening
it's where the violence the intensity
the beauty
of all of these blasts is taking place i
want to
show you some of the most striking
volcanoes on earth
and i'm doing this because i want to try
to better understand why they are so
deadly
and why millions of people live right in
the shadow of these
sleeping dragons
[Music]
okay let's quickly go over why volcanoes
exist maybe you've heard this before but
i'm going to try to explain
it in a way that makes sense it's
important to remember that the ground
under your feet is actually a giant
plate 100 kilometers thick one of many
plates
floating around on molten lava they're
all moving in certain directions and at
different speeds
there are seven main plates on earth and
a bunch of smaller ones
and they're always moving when these
plates move into each other they make
mountains
when they spread apart they make
underwater volcanoes that cool and turn
into rocks and we call them islands
when they slide against each other they
make terrible earthquakes and when they
run into each other and one gets
forced below the other they make
volcanoes
a whole series of volcanoes begins to
pop up along the edge of the continent
parallel to the trench
so the real reason why this one strip of
land in indonesia has so many volcanoes
is because this plate is slamming into
this plate at a rate of seven
centimeters a year which is one of the
fastest movements of plates in the world
so you're getting a ton of this which
results in a ton
of this
if you zoom into one of these volcanoes
you're going to see a lot of this
dark green around the volcano where no
one lives
but all of this each one of these little
dots are villages
where tons of people live and they're
right in the strike zone of this volcano
volcanoes kill people when they suddenly
erupt
but it's not the lava that kills them
it's the ash
this huge column of ash and gases first
goes up
and then it eventually falls down as it
falls it gains momentum
on these steep mountainsides and
eventually that will slam
into villages up to three kilometers in
radius from the volcano if you are
standing in the way of one of these
massive ash avalanches you will die
and then if it rains it gets really bad
because the ash and the rain
make these horrifying mud rivers that
cut through the mountain
and flood villages all around the region
okay before we go any further i want to
thank today's sponsor which is morning
brew
morning brew is a free daily newsletter
monday through sunday
i love morning brew because it is a
great way to start your day
i used to start my mornings just sort of
like rolling over opening my phone and
wandering through several apps not
really knowing what i should be reading
morning brew is a clear concise and
honestly witty and fun to read
newsletter
that focuses you on the relevant news in
everything from tech
to business to what's happening in the
world one of the things i've been
following
is the cryptocurrency world and
obviously i've made a video about nfts
they're witty they're asking the right
questions it's just
a really nice solid breakdown that's fun
and very
quick and easy to read again there's
nothing to sell here morning brew is a
free newsletter it takes 15 seconds to
sign up there's a link in my description
clicking that link helps support this
channel but it also allows you to sign
up for this awesome
newsletter for five minutes a day you're
getting smarter and more informed about
today's news thank you morningbroof for
sponsoring this video
and let's get back to volcanoes every
volcano has its own personality and i
want to show you some of the most
striking volcanoes along this
strip and in the process explain how and
why humans live
so close to these sleeping dragons
[Music]
first let's talk about kawaii zhen this
volcano blew up
really bad 3000 years ago and left a one
kilometer wide crater that is now full
of this bright blue very
acidic water the most acidic lake on
earth because under the surface
there is a huge deposit of sulfuric gas
that is venting out of this crack in the
earth all of this sulfuric gas
means that when this thing erupts with
lava it burns
that gas and ignites it in this
mesmerizing blue flame
all of this gas also means that there is
some money to be made
the locals have installed these ceramic
pipes to catch the gases and
force it to condense into a liquid it
flows down here to where it cools and
turns into a solid which can be
harvested by locals my friend christian
is there right now
covering the realities of this job i'm
gonna let him show you
what this work is actually like
hey johnny so right now we are inside of
kawaiigen
a active volcano and this crater is
full of life you can see all the steam
rising off of the water
this insane plume of yellow smoke and
this yellow smoke
is what creates the sulfur and with me
here are the
bad ass hard-working dudes no other way
to put it they're literal superheroes
this here is superno what's up superno
i've had this amazing opportunity to
just pick his brain
try to understand a little bit better
why is it that these guys
have taking on some of the most
challenging work conditions
on planet earth what is the heaviest
weight that you'll take up the hill
uh 75 kilograms 75 kilograms
i just tried 40 could barely manage it i
mean you look at these guys they're not
bodybuilders
but they're strong-minded they're
incredibly driven
and they've got a good purpose for it
how much money for one kilo
only 1250.
so how much do you make at the end of
the day okay
if you were to convert that to us
dollars that's about 22
21 for the entire day's worth of work
[Music]
these workers make it into town where
they sell this sulfur to factories
which mainly use it to bleach sugar so
that it's white it's back-breaking
dangerous work christian made a whole
video
from this mine and the realities of this
war
i will link to that in the description
next up we have mount merapi
or fire mountain this volcano has killed
more humans
than any other it erupts all of the time
like every few years
here it is erupting just last year this
thing is happening over the course of
five minutes this time lapse was
recorded by
volcano ut and freck on two different
youtube channels that i'll link to in
the description the reason why this
volcano is so deadly
is because like i said before there are
millions of people living around it
and not just remotely around it like
right up against the mountain here's the
volcano
and these are all the villages right up
against it
which raises an important question i had
going into this story which is
why do so many people live here like so
many people
the answer is that this is an amazing
place
to live
indonesia has mild warm weather it rains
super hard for a few months and that
rain is effectively stored
in these mountains and it provides water
to these people throughout the year
and then there's the fact that this is
perfect fertilizer
all mashed up and broken down ready to
make this soil
incredibly fertile this is some of the
most fertile land on earth
you get three rice harvests from this
soil every year
because the soil is like magic so yeah
the people living here are sort of in a
high risk high reward situation they
live on a sleeping dragon
that could wipe them out at any moment
and yet as long as it doesn't they have
some of the best weather
and growing conditions on earth
[Music]
next up is krakatoa what you're looking
at here is actually like
a graveyard of what used to be a big
island they used to look a lot more like
this but a hundred years ago it blew up
we think this is the most explosive
volcano in modern history
10 of the world could hear the blast it
was so intense
tens of thousands were killed in the ash
and the ash exploded so high into the
air
that all the way in europe the sky was
red
and hazy which has led some to speculate
that it was this event that inspired the
red
hazy look of this painting one of the
most famous paintings in the world
called the scream
the volcano that grew out of krakatoa
has kept erupting over the years
breaking this island down further and
further until the whole thing just
eventually collapsed and caused a huge
tsunami that killed hundreds
just a couple of years ago the island
went from looking like this
to this and today it's one of the
fastest growing volcanoes in the world
and will certainly
be back for more destruction
[Music]
okay the last one i want to talk about
is this set of volcanoes
this one is mount bromo and this one is
mount semeru
first off these two volcanoes are some
of the most stunning volcanoes i've ever
seen in my life
but they also represent the deep
religious symbolism that volcanoes
have come to symbolize over time this
mountain mount sumeru
is named after the mythical mount meru
which is a
sacred five-peaked mountain in the
cosmology of three religions hindu jain
and buddhism it is considered to be the
center of the physical
and metaphysical and spiritual universes
the neighboring volcano is also
deeply symbolic it's called bromo which
in javanese is the name for
brahma or the hindu god of creation
every year
hindus hike up this mountain and make an
offering of
vegetables and plants and animals to the
gods
embodied in this volcano
there are so many more volcanoes in
indonesia and my goal
is to go to indonesia with my camera
and actually photograph them for myself
a lot of the footage from this video
came from christian who gave me a lot of
his footage he lives in indonesia and
from other places
i didn't go there but i really want to
i'm now deeply fascinated with volcanoes
because i've been
deeply diving into plate tectonics so i
hope you understand more about
why volcanoes exist why so many exist in
indonesia and how the people cope living
next to
these ticking time bombs what's so
intriguing to me is that the volcano
is a giver it gives abundance and
fertility most of the time
but sometimes it chooses to take away
[Music]
okay that's it